man they should be in their wallets
it's ridiculous
you have so much love and goodwill out
there you really do and and to such a
degree that first of all I mentioned the
crowd yesterday you were coming on the
show place goes insane as if and then
that's sad but when you had a just a I
guess a signing of some of the DVDs or
in a personal appearance at one of the
record stores in Midtown what lines
around the block people thousand people
showed up yeah it's incredible do you
find now that because of you know what
you've achieved in your show business
career that you get special treatment do
people treat you differently now I had a
real weird special treatment thing
happened to me recently I had to go get
my driver's license renewed
mhm and yeah in California have to take
the written test again so I go to the
DMV in Hollywood and I'm thinking like I
hope I get recognized I never really
think that but I thought like this would
be a good place for that to happen cuz
it's a long law it's a long line and you
thought sure why not I want to get out
of there a little faster so I'm trying
to judge this woman and see like is she
gonna recognize me and I'm kind of
deciding no she's not and then I see a
guy right behind her go like and run
over and go like sir come right this way
please
and all of a sudden I'm behind the
counter where you never get to go and
one more second later he opens the door
and I'm in the bowels of the DMV we're
like you don't even see this area right
and he puts me in a little cubicle gives
me the test and a pencil and I sit down
and he goes I'll be right back you'll be
much more comfortable here I go great
this is just right yeah I sit down I
studied for the test I had a little
booklet I studied very hard I did the
first question I did the second question
the third question I could tell was a
trick question so I decided I'm gonna
come back to this right so I go to the
fourth right I do the fifth right the
guy comes back and he's standing over
top of me and he goes you didn't do
number three and I go yeah I can tell
it's a trick question I'm gonna come
back to that he goes see
so I immediately panicked I immediately
thought like you know there's like a
hidden camera somewhere it's like a
sting like it's gonna be some kind of
you're gonna be caught cheating yeah
celebrity perks like the DMV some weird
thing so I go you know I'm fine I
you know I studied he goes e to the next
one he gives me another answer I go huh
great okay look I'm fine you know I'm
really getting terrified okay so I do a
couple more I hesitate for a minute he
goes B so I finally finish okay fine
fine so he leaves I finished the test he
comes back he grades it mm-hmm I did
really well on it he hands me a piece of
paper that has all the employees of that
particular DMV office with a little box
next to each name and they send the
paper around going and pee-wee Herman's
here if you're interested and you chip
make a little check mark by your name
and he hands me this thing and there
were 60 autographs to do with the DMV
office right address on it so I had to
go home and sign you know payment for
helping you with the test that you
didn't need any help with yeah plus I
mean I did it believe me I did it I went
home and signed him and sent him in the
mail because I was afraid if I didn't
I'd you know be stopped somewhere and it
would turn out my license was fake or
something that's not my picture that's a
chicken yeah well I mean I think he did
the right thing I do too
you did now
they're looking another word yes they
are there I'm curious about you know
you've had such a unique career you
create this character that cuts many
people's imagination and and and and and
you're so good at what you do but do you
ever think about what you would have
done had you not been an actor if you
had gone a different way if you didn't
go into acting what would you do this is
gonna sound like I'm joking but this is
this is really what I thought I would
wind up doing I grew up in Sarasota
Florida which is the old winter
headquarters of Ringling Brothers and I
always thought I'd wind up in the circus
that's what I thought I was going really
yeah what did you want to do in the
circus did you have a specific like did
you see okay this is I could do a lot of
circus acts I could do trapeze I could
do tightrope
see I thought I knew you were gonna
think did you really did you practically
did you totally seriously we went to
circus camp there's a circus camp as a
child I went to circus camp about six
weeks into the circus camp we put on a
big show my parents came they're sitting
in the bleachers and I run out I got on
a little speedo bathing suit I'm like
maybe 12 okay I've got like a I get up
on the balance beam at a balance beam
act it's a fantastic balance beam I wish
you guys could have seen it and I had
like fire I had a ring like that had
fire around it and I blindfold myself
and skip through the ring and I looked
out my parents were like I think it was
then they knew
[Laughter]